there was a Google engineer that claimed
that the Lambda was sentient do you
think there's any inkling of Truth
to what he felt and more importantly to
me at least do you think language models
will achieve sentience or the illusion
of sentience
sunish fish yeah to me it's a little bit
of a canary in a coal mine kind of
moment honestly a little bit because uh
so this engineer spoke to like a chatbot
at Google and uh became convinced that
uh this bot is sentient asked some
existential philosophical questions and
it gave like reasonable answers and
looked real and uh and so on so to me
it's a
he was he was uh he wasn't sufficiently
trying to stress the system I think and
uh exposing the truth of it as it is
today
um
but uh I think this will be increasingly
harder over time uh so uh yeah I think
more and more people will basically uh
become
um
yeah I think more and more there will be
more people like that over time as this
gets better like form an emotional
connection to to an AI yeah perfectly
plausible in my mind I think these AIS
are actually quite good at human human
connection human emotion a ton of text
on the Internet is about humans and
connection and love and so on so I think
they have a very good understanding in
some in some sense of of how people
speak to each other about this and um
they're very capable of creating a lot
of that kind of text the um
there's a lot of like sci-fi from 50s
and 60s that imagined AIS in a very
different way they are calculating cold
vulcan-like machines that's not what
we're getting today we're getting pretty
emotional AIS that actually uh are very
competent and capable of generating
you know possible sounding text with
respect to all these topics see I'm
really hopeful about AI systems that are
like companions that help you grow
develop as a human being help you
maximize long-term happiness but I'm
also very worried about AI systems that
figure out from the internet the humans
get attracted to drama and so these
would just be like [ __ ] talking AIS
that's just constantly did you hear like
they'll do gossip they'll do uh they'll
try to plant seeds of Suspicion to other
humans that you love and trust and just
kind of mess with people uh in the you
know because because that's going to get
a lot of attention so drama maximize
drama on the path to maximizing uh
engagement and US humans will feed into
that machine yeah and get it'll be a
giant drama [ __ ] storm uh yeah so I'm
worried about that so it's the objective
function really defines the way that
human civilization progresses with ai's
in it yeah I think right now at least
today they are not sort of it's not
correct to really think of them as goal
seeking agents that want to do something
they have no long-term memory or
anything they it's literally a good
approximation of it is you get a
thousand words and you're trying to
predict a thousand at first and then you
continue feeding it in and you are free
to prompt it in whatever way you want so
in text so you say okay you are a
psychologist and you are very good and
you love humans and here's a
conversation between you and another
human human colon Something you
something and then it just continues the
pattern and suddenly you're having a
conversation with a fake psychologist
who's not trying to help you and so it's
still kind of like in a realm of a tool
it is a um people can prompt their
arbitrary ways and it can create really
incredible text but it doesn't have
long-term goals over long periods of
time it doesn't try to uh so it doesn't
look that way right now yeah but you can
do short-term goals that have long-term
effects so if my prompting
short-term goal is to get Andre kapati
to respond to me on Twitter when I
like I think AI might that's the goal
but he might figure out that talking
[ __ ] to you it would be the best in a
highly sophisticated interesting way and
then you build up a relationship when
you respond once and then it
like over time it gets to not be
sophisticated and just
like just talk [ __ ]
and okay maybe you won't get to Andre
but it might get to another celebrity it
might get into other big accounts and
then it'll just so with just that simple
goal get them to respond yeah maximize
the probability of actual response yeah
I mean you could prompt a uh powerful
model like this with their its opinion
about how to do any possible thing
you're interested in so they will
discuss they're kind of on track to
become these oracles I could sort of
think of it that way they are oracles uh
currently it's just text but they will
have calculators they will have access
to Google search they will have all
kinds of gadgets and gizmos they will be
able to operate the internet and find
different information and
um
yeah in some sense
that's kind of like currently what it
looks like in terms of the development
do you think it'll be an improvement
eventually over what Google is for
access to human knowledge like it'll be
a more effective search engine to access
human knowledge I think there's definite
scope in building a better search engine
today and I think Google they have all
the tools all the people they have
everything they need they have all the
puzzle pieces they have people training
Transformers at scale they have all the
data uh it's just not obvious if they
are capable as an organization to
innovate on their search engine right
now and if they don't someone else will
there's absolute scope for building a
significantly better search engine built
on these tools it's so interesting a
large company where the search there's
already an infrastructure it works as
brings out a lot of money so where
structurally inside a company is their
motivation to Pivot yeah to say we're
going to build a new search engine yep
that's really hard so it's usually going
to come from a startup right that's um
that would be yeah or some other more
competent organization
um so uh I don't know so currently for
example maybe Bing has another shot at
it you know so Microsoft Edge because
we're talking offline
um I mean I definitely it's really
interesting because search engines used
to be about okay here's some query
here's here's here's web pages that look
like the stuff that you have but you
could just directly go to answer and
then have supporting evidence
um and these uh these models basically
they've read all the texts and they've
read all the web pages and so sometimes
when you see yourself going over the
search results and sort of getting like
a sense of like the average answer to
whatever you're interested in uh like
that just directly comes out you don't
have to do that work
um
so they're kind of like uh
yeah I think they have a way to this of
distilling all that knowledge into
like some level of insight basically do
you think of prompting as a kind of
teaching and learning like this whole
process like another layer
you know because maybe that's what
humans are we already have that
background model and then your the world
is prompting you yeah exactly I think
the way we are programming these
computers now like gpts is is converging
to how you program humans I mean how do
I program humans via prompt I go to
people and I I prompt them to do things
I prompt them from information and so uh
natural language prompt is how we
program humans and we're starting to
program computers directly in that
interface it's like pretty remarkable
honestly